es la noticia que millones de franceses
habían esperado luz verde para la vacuna
de facer contra el coronavirus si
confirmamos que esta vacuna se puede
utilizar en personas mayores de 16 años
incluidos los ancianos y si la mls
esto significa que francia ahora puede
seguir adelante con su estrategia de
lanzamiento de vacunas que ya había sido
implementada por el gobierno en enero
del próximo año los residentes de
hogares de ancianos que acepten
vacunarse serán los primeros en la fila
junto con los propios cuidadores a
partir de febrero en la segunda fase se
vacunará a las personas mayores
vulnerables fuera de los hogares de
ancianos y a las personas con problemas
de salud y una vida de justicia y tú se
casa en una asistencia
si logramos proteger a esta parte de la
población que ronda los 15 millones de
personas podríamos asumir que ya no
existiría el riesgo de que los
hospitales se saturen el distanciamiento
social debería continuar pero ya no
habría necesidad de cerrar al país
imponiendo bloque 1 nada provisional de
la gestión a ese sitio ante la falta de
datos las autoridades aún tienen que
aprobar la vacuna para mujeres
embarazadas o personas con alergias
graves durante el lanzamiento los
efectos secundarios se registrarán y se
tramitarán
autoridades sanitarias a continuación se
solicitará a la agencia nacional de
medicamentos de francia que evalúe los
riesgos que plantea la vacuna antes de
tomar una decisión que pueda afectar su
uso